[Music]
okay so when this premieres again
Roseanne it's gonna be almost 30 years
since the first time oh my god I
remember so many things Roseanne is back
the ABC revival returns to TV on March
27th with all the signature humor and
cast returning when the trailer we see
everybody kind of laughing off Dan's
death as a joke if they were listen to
me where they had a whole zombie thing
going you know right away like we we got
a little magic sauce going on and I'm
Adam
we had the similar sense of humor and
we're both really bitter we really just
hit it off right from the jump like we
always do now we just make each other
laugh one of the things we love so much
about you and the Conner families that
you all never shied away from the
controversial episodes or the issues
you're gonna pick up where you left off
right so your no shying away from
anything no just going to show what you
know a realistic depiction of this
family and you know they have so much in
common with other American families
everybody's mad at everybody in so we'll
find our way through and hopefully other
people will two things that affect
families in Middle America they're gonna
affect us and we we want to be not
demonstrating Richards just showing up
it affects a family who were living
paycheck-to-paycheck how they handle
these things and how much they have to
forget just to get through the day
I don't know mom can I have some money
you know that people are gonna want more
than 9 episodes
oh yeah we're down for it we hope we get
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]